hello everyone today we're going to be
talking about galaxies and gravity we
know the earth is a planet that is in
orbit around the sun this is called the
heliocentric model and the solar system
is an enormous space for us encompassing
every place that humans or our robots
have ever been but it's actually quite
small cosmically speaking
even our furthest spacecraft voyager 1
has only traveled less than 0.1 percent
of the distance to the nearest star
our solar system is just a small
component of a much much larger set of
structures
the sun is just one star of hundreds of
billions of stars in our galaxy which is
called the milky way and our galaxy is
one of several dozen in our galaxy group
which is called the local group other
galaxies might belong to larger
collections that are called galaxy
clusters
now the same thing that holds earth in
its orbit around the sun is what holds
together massive groups and clusters of
galaxies
gravity
this is the same as the gravity that
makes a ball fall back to the ground
when you toss it up into the air
gravity is a force that operates between
two objects that have mass and tries to
pull them closer together whether those
objects are a ball in the earth or two
galaxies
now the strength of this pole depends on
two things first is the mass of both
objects so as either object gets more
massive the strength of gravity
increases for example you have a lot
more mass than a ball so the force of
gravity between you and the earth is
pulling harder than the force of gravity
between a ball and the earth and that's
why it's a lot harder to throw you into
the air than a ball
gravity also depends on the distance
between the centers of the objects as
the objects get farther apart the
strength of gravity decreases
for example if there is a ball on top of
mount everest the pole of earth's
gravity on it is actually slightly less
than the pull of gravity on that same
ball at sea level because the top of the
mountain is farther away from the center
of the earth
now this is a very small effect less
than a percent difference because the
difference between sea level and
mountaintop is still very small compared
to the distance to the center of the
earth
but that's just on earth we know that
things in space are really far apart the
earth is almost 93 million miles that's
150 million kilometers from the sun
so if gravity is weaker when objects are
farther apart then in order for gravity
to be keeping these structures bound
together they must be really massive and
they are
the sun has a mass of about 2 million
kilograms that's 10 to the power of 30.
and the milky way galaxy which is about
a quintillion kilometers in diameter has
a mass of about 1.5 trillion times that
of the sun
so thanks to their high masses objects
like our milky way galaxy and our
nearest neighbor the andromeda galaxy
which are the two largest galaxies in
the local group can be pulled together
by gravity even across millions of light
years
in fact gravity between our two galaxies
is so strong that it's actually pulling
the milky way and andromeda galaxies
together into an eventual collision
but eventually in this case means almost
5 billion years from now so no need to
worry
to review in this video we covered how
the earth is part of the solar system
and our solar system is part of a galaxy
and our galaxy is part of a group
galaxy groups galaxies and solar systems
are all bound together by the same force
that of gravity
gravity is a force which tries to pull
objects with mass closer together and it
is weaker for less massive objects or
for objects that are farther apart
thanks for watching and i hope you
learned a little bit of something